[Musique]
oui je suis très gros j'adore les petits
suisses
mon frère et des chefs maman équipe
excellente ligne est alors oui j'aime
bien manger et a fondu bien sûr les
craies c'est facile à faire
j'envoie un message arnaud il me dit
comment tout faire et voilà ne faisait
pas compliqué et si c'est quelque chose
que j'aime beaucoup leur montrer de mes
racines
l'aligot
[Musique]
la plus commode là on se sent bien
je souffre un peu avec cette partie de
vêtements et qu'est ce que je vais m
j'ai un programme à faire j'ai tout ça
berger toujours quelqu'un qui qui peut
m'aider je remercie beaucoup ça parce
que je suis très habituelle qu'ils
disent mais ça parce que le personnage
maîtresse a alors voilà je suis je suis
très très obéissants alors comme un
style propre j'aime l'aide commun et je
suis très classique très très classique
j'aime pas être trop sexy les
personnages le point c'est avec moi
alors dans la vie je ne le suis pas
tellement
oui j'ai quatre chiens j'ai un grand
terre-neuve qui s'appelle nous qu'à un
petit york qui s'appelle tout si un
autre york qui s'appelle au ski et
douglas que c'est un petit chat la rue
il n'y a pas de secret il faut bien
dormir et un petit secret ou peut-être
que si ça peut vous aider si vous l'avez
encore pas entendu c'est un peu d'eau
chaude avec quelques gouttes de citron
[Musique]